indoor outdoor living open space so
stupid what do they call now indoor
outdoor living and then it's like uh
open floor plan it has an open floor
plan look over here's where you make
cookies and while you do that you can
watch somebody watching TV it's like I
like the walls open floor plan is great
until you have a fight with your wife
and then you just can't get away from
her I mean walls save
marriages can't just have her looking at
you just hating everything about you
staring at the back of your head she's
out in the kitchen there's a skillet she
just starts thinking like what if I just
grabbed it and walked over whacked him
on the head